Selbstversorgung schön und gut aber bei
mir würde das nicht klappen das ist
einer der häufigsten Kommentare die ich
unter meinen Videos lese darf ich
vorstellen das ist Bea sie lebt auf 1000
Metern Höhe in den Schweizer Alpen in
einem Haus mit einem sehr steilen
Hanggrundstück als sie die Idee hatte
ihr eigenes Gemüse anzubauen hat sie oft
gehört dass das sowieso nicht klappen
würde zum Glück hat sie sich nicht
wehren lassen das steile Grundstück
therasiert und einfach losgelegt und wow
schaut euch Ihren Garten jetzt an sie
baut sogar Pfirsiche Kumquats und Feigen
an Bär ist eine der Teilnehmerinnen in
meinem Onlinekurs Gemüsegarten starten
und eine Sache die ich dort immer wieder
predige ist macht das Beste aus dem was
du hast selbst wenn dein Garten auf den
ersten Blick nicht perfekt ist oder du
in Anführungszeichen nur einen Balkon
oder eine Fensterbank hast kannst du so
viel selber anbauen und das Gefühl die
eigene Ernte in die Küche zu tragen ist
einfach unbeschreiblich